was any of this art imitating life
because you did get emotional at the end
of the season in your speech to your
cast this has been the strangest life
imitating art for me that i've ever had
in my career and i have
not been able to i would have never been
able to get through this without each of
you one of you saved me each day
for the last seven months and i owe you
all the biggest thank you what made you
emotional oh my gosh yes so
these last many months have been
tumultuous for probably
everybody for a different reason or
whatnot and mine was definitely no
different i was playing these characters
that were very intense and a lot of
self-hatred and a lot of emotion and
then going home and dealing with my own
emotion i never really had an escape
which as an actor it's actually what we
love is to go be someone else for the
day you know so early on i was very
honest with my team my team being my
producers and my crew and i pretty much
made an announcement to everyone and i
said i need help and i said it very
early on because in season one i was my
hand was in everything they called me
the octopus i did it all i was a
multi-tasker at its finest and also
being able to be very present well that
was just not the case for me this year
and i was aware of that from the
beginning and i wasn't going to go out
there and pretend that i could hold
everything together and saying the words
i need help is the hardest thing for
someone like us you know we we help
others like we take care of stuff right
and so saying that out loud almost broke
me and then i realized how many people
wanted to help me and how much help i
got from all different walks my
producers my family my friends and it
was kind of weird because kaylee i
wasn't being honest with myself into the
background
you know i'm so sick of him stealing my
thunder he's down here all day i'm
sitting here pouring my heart out and
here comes dumpy probably gonna take a
dump right here right in front of us or
he's he's also asleep standing i don't
know what's happening nope he's gone
well so much for my deep feeling
you were really taking us to church at
that moment i mean we're talking about
needing help all that in here comes
dumping this waddles himself through as
i'm just crying from my soul look and
then you've got sweet ruby who's just
being so quiet in the background
well thanks a lot jumpy so sick of that
dog let me tell you he is
all my instagram followers he has taken
all my friends and family i'm telling
you anyway aside from dumpy being
hilarious my point is it was a big deal
to kind of say i couldn't do it all this
year and i was finally honest with
myself that i couldn't and it's amazing
that when you rarely say that and when
you do say it people really want to help
you and um i took it and it got me
through i mean my cr even to my crew i
mean these people i was with these
people all day every day and they saw me
in all different emotions and all
different feelings and i was very honest
with them i mean there were days i'd
walk in i'm like guys having the worst
day and i would like announce and they
were all just and then other days we
were having the best time and it was a
kind of an amazing experience and again
it was it was kind of self-acceptance
for myself and self-acceptance for
cassie it just all feels
pretty great thank you for naming a
powerhouse female character cassie okay
oh my goodness it was named after you
and this is your mo i wanted to tell you
that on this segment she is named after
you i hope you're not as insane as she
is but she's named after you so maybe a
guest spot in a season three
oh my god you people in the season three
conversation can we just air season two
well i apparently missed the photos you
did you're right you're right there's
been a lot of a lot of conversation
about that recently so you're right
you're right it's i'm open to the idea
and if we do you're in baby music to my
ears congratulations my friend on season
two i'm starting to think that someone
is pretending to be me it sounds like
someone's trying to frame you i have
worked so hard to build this new life
and i am holding on to it with
everything that i have
how would you describe this second
go-around for the flight attendant
joe can you say that on entertainment
tonight we are now
um it's insane we are bigger and better
than we were season one i was very
nervous to do a season two to be honest
because season one was so good i was
like guys we got away with it let's go
leave it leave it just let's move on
with our lives but we came back swinging
and it is bigger in scope we have world
travel i play five cassies guess who i
don't want to work with ever again
myself so i'm ready to move on to other
people who are you i'm you silly what
was that like playing multiple cassies
and having yourself as your own scene
partner how challenging was that i can't
stand working with myself i learned that
and i have a lot of empathy for the
people that work with me daily so that's
been eye-opening talked about that in
therapy that's good technically it was
extremely difficult and the reason why
as an actor i'm very in the moment i'm
just i'm reactive i would i'm not a
preparer i i've never admitted to being
that way i like to be in the moment i
like to do different things and i improv
a lot this process is the direct
opposite there is no improv i have to be
exact in my motions i have to mimic what
i did in the previous take and then i
had doubles uh different girls that were
playing me and it was crazy and i would
come in and do one cassie and i would
shoot her for however many hours and
then we'd lock it and i'd go change into
a different cassie and i would come back
i'd be able to watch it in video village
they put me next to myself and so i
would be working against myself even
though myself wasn't really there i even
after doing this for seven months i have
no idea what we did it's giving me
parent trap vibes
yeah well that's just two so she had it
easy and you had five and still yeah
i didn't make one of the five cassies
but you know what i'm gonna let it go
obviously this season we see cassie
thriving in her sober journey in a new
city i mean what aspect in particular
were you excited to explore with cass
this time around she's cast to me i love
that now she's cast annie calls her cast
so i love that we moved to la you know
we open on season two with her living in
california oh my god la traffic is
insane but i am not late mark that down
in your little notepad if you're not
early you're late okay benjamin that is
an impossible bar i will never be able
to reach she's really painting a pretty
picture a sober life she's healthy she's
very happy she's like miss aa she's got
the cia asset job which she takes very
seriously i kind of took it as you know
she took the alcohol away which is her
high and now this new job is kind of
taking that place that excitement that
she feels that she's lost with becoming
sober even though she's pretending she's
happy but we find out very quickly very
quickly that she's not only lying to
everyone else but i think the saddest
part about this show is she's truly
lying to herself she just cannot face
herself and she's been running away from
her problems from the beginning what is
it really like off camera when getting
your entire cast together oh my gosh i
do really thrive on leading and doing
especially at work look we this was such
a serious show at moments and yes i had
my my troubles over this last year but i
thrived on doing fun things for this
crew i was always trying to bring in ice
cream trucks and donuts and do different
things that can entertain people and i
think last season we did oh my god we
had
oh the um candy makers and just things
that would make them you know excited
and after a long 12 13 hour day and
you're trying to get one more hour out
of them it it just means a lot you know
and i wanted them to know how much i
appreciated them i mean i felt i was
there all day they're there before me
and after and it's just amazing how many
hands are involved to put a show
together and i i scream that to the
world i'm ashamed i feel like i didn't
know that before before i started
shooting this show how much work it
takes and how many people are involved
and more people involved this year too
because you have some new faces joining
this season sharon stone as your tv mom
you have cheryl hines margaret cho were
you responsible for getting the gals
together was this you texting them
saying hey wanna come be on my show oh
my god i wish i could say that i do have
one story about a certain person that
i'm very proud that i got on the show so
we were casting grace and we were
watching different tapes and all these
different actresses sending in their
videos i had just gotten done watching
feelgood on netflix i woke up the next
morning i was like may martin is grace
and i called the team and they were like
whoa like that's really interesting i'm
like that's it there's no that's who
needs to play this so we tracked mae
down and we're like do you think that
they would put themselves on tape like
do you think they'd even be interested
and they did and i was literally because
i had really gone out on a limb here i
was like i hope there as good as as i
think they're gonna be they were
brilliant we hired may and it was the
best decision they have seen stealing
moments in this show and i'm just so
proud of it and they've become a great
friend and it all made me very happy one
word to describe sharon stone as your tv
mom gorgeous i've never seen anyone more
beautiful in person at moments i was
like is it weird that your daughter is
staring at you in a very creepily creepy
like i would find myself and i just be
like because i was looking at her face
and like whose face looks like that
it was a phenomenal well perfectly
casted because girl look at you
beautiful inside and out thank you
cassie
[Music]
you